[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 8 février
bienvenue dans cette édition sûreté des
78 encore largement tournée vers la
neige et ses conséquences dans le
département tout de suite les titres de
se situer du journal est la vigilance
orange maintenue ce soir et jusqu'à
samedi dans les yvelines le territoire a
connu aujourd'hui et des températures
négatives puis un léger répit dans la
journée mais de nouvelles chutes de
neige sont attendues demain
elle nous sommes allés voir comment
guillaucourt se prépare à ce nouvel
épisode
elle nous ferons le point également sur
la météo des prochaines heures
conséquence des intempéries l'activité
économique a été fortement ralenti hier
beaucoup de salariés n'ont pas pu se
rendre sur leur lieu de travail quelle
était la situation aujourd'hui à saint
quentin en yvelines reportage et puis on
aurait bien besoin d'un héros à d'un
aéroglisseur pour se déplacer avec des
conditions de route difficile justement
l'estaca et le lycée louis-blériot de
trappes en conçoivent un en ce moment un
projet commun que nous avons pu suivre
invitée ce journal tout à l'heure
l'yvelinois christian portes à lille
signe l'occident un malade de sa
médecine un livre critique sur notre
système et nos pratiques en termes de
santé c'est à suivre dans ce journal est
la neige a laissé place aujourd'hui au
verglas vous étiez nombreux ce matin à
marcher lentement pour éviter la chute
sur des sols très glissants
il était dû à la météo glaciale de la
nuit dernière dans les yvelines jusqu'à
-10 degrés localement plus tard le
soleil a fait son apparition améliorant
légèrement la situation m et demain a
déjà on vous en parlera tout à l'heure
la neige devrait faire son retour
et depuis le début des intempéries les
communes et collectivités sont
pleinement mobilisées opérations de
salage et de déneigement de la chaussée
elle se préparaient désormais à de
nouvelles chutes de neige demain
en coulisses les services continue donc
d'être sur le qui vive
comme vous allez le voir à guyancourt
avec ce sujet de mélanie poquet 14h cet
après midi à la mairie de guyancourt ont
fait le point sur les intempéries des
jours précédents et surtout celles à
venir une à trois réunions par jour
[Musique]
c'est des moments importants puisqu'on à
l'ensemble effectivement des services de
la ville qui sont mobilisés on permet de
faire le point sur la météo sur lémance
effectivement la météo de voir aussi le
travail que les agents de la ville font
sur les voiries il faut penser à
accueillir les enfants dans les crèches
continue à les garder dans les crèches
ou dans les écoles
bien après l'heure effectivement de
fermeture pour sécuriser les parents une
évaluation presque heure par heure
depuis mardi après midi ce jeudi une
inquiétude apparaît le sel 40 tonnes ont
été déversées dans les rues la moitié du
stock communal on a recommandé à 80
paraître la semaine prochaine on espère
les avoir un grosso modo pour bien des
salles et suit un événement comme hier
la vie sur les axes du primaire
secondaire et également le tout ce
qu'ils aient accès aux services publics
nous faut une journée et demie avec un
travail ininterrompu de la saleuse et
des hommes à pied 44 à 100 agents tous
services confondus sont mobilisées jour
et nuit la neige devrait revenir dans
les yvelines au vendredi la salle aux
clients courtoise reprendra du service
dès trois heures du matin
la météo donc au centre de toutes les
attentions d'autant plus que un nouvel
épisode neigeux est attendu pour demain
bonsoir au rayon de la rédaction de tv
78 comment la la situation at elle
évolué ce jeudi et surtout comment
va-t-elle se poursuivre cette nuit
alors aujourd'hui c'était une journée de
transition selon les services de météo
france vous l'avez constaté dans les
yvelines
il n'a pas neigé on a eu un très beau
soleil et les températures étaient même
légèrement positive une bonne partie de
l'après midi
en revanche pour demain grégory le ciel
sera de nouveau capricieux comme le
confirme frédéric mizrahi lé
prévisionniste au centre météorologique
de trappes
il est au micro de nicolas kirillovitch
eu malheureusement vendredi une nouvelle
perturbation qui arrive le matin une
perturbation neigeuse autres des neiges
quand même qu'ils pourraient apporter
3,5 cm de neige avec un redoux qui sera
très faible et insuffisant pour faire
fondre cette neige
donc ça c'est des centimètres qui vont
se rajouter à ce qu on a déjà
actuellement sur nos sur nos sols alors
vous l'avez compris au programme pour
demain un retour de la neige et des
températures négatives et c'est surtout
entre 12h et 16h que les averses de
neige seront plus intenses
elle devrait être plus espacées à partir
de 19h
malgré tout météo france annonce des
hauteurs de neige inférieure à celle de
l'épisode de mardi à mercredi
et sachez qu'il faudra attendre mercredi
prochain brit-brit pour avoir un vrai
road
alors nous avons pu voir aurélie depuis
deux jours des scènes de chaos des
milliers d'automobilistes bloqués sur
les accès ce que l'on peut craindre
demain encore de la pagaille sur les
routes alors en tout cas aujourd'hui
cela glisser un bien sûr en raison du
verglas est néanmoins aucun phénomène
majeur à signaler vous avez été en effet
nombreux à laisser votre voiture au
garage
toutefois sachez que la n118 la fameuse
n118 est fermée dans les deux sens de
circulation entre le pont de sèvres et
les ulis concernant lé poids lourds de +
7 de plus de 7 tonnes 5
eh bien ils ont le droit et de circuler
jusqu'à demain matin 5 heures et ce afin
de vider les zones de stockage alors
pour demain dans un communiqué la
préfecture recommande de ne pas utiliser
sa voiture en ile de france
les chaussées seront en effet et
glissante on l'a dit
aura donc de la neige est évidemment des
températures des températures négatives
avec un risque de verglas
faut-il du coup évité une nouvelle fois
d'utiliser son véhicule et privilégier
les transports en commun alors cette
option est fortement bien sûr recommandé
par les autorités mais eh bien sachez
qu'il faudra prendre et des délais car
il y aura vraisemblablement à des
retards d'ailleurs pour les transiliens
compter trois trains sur quatre pour la
ligne une même prévisions à trois trains
sur quatre pour la ligne n pour la ligne
c du rer le trafic risque également
d'être perturbé pour les bus le réseau
stibus fonctionner normalement
aujourd'hui
mais pour l'heure aucune annonce pour
demain compte tenu des chutes de neige
attendues
il risque d'y avoir des difficultés vous
pouvez bien sûr vous tenir informés sur
le site www.sgbourse.fr enfin pour le
réseau fébus le service de bus
desservant versailles saint cyr et
vélizy toutes les lignes fonctionner
quasiment normalement aujourd'hui
mais pour demain pas encore de
prévisions annoncées une information à
présent aurélie attendu par tous les
parents qui nous regardent qu'en est il
pour demain dans les écoles alors la
préfecture des yvelines a annoncé que
les transports scolaires resté suspendu
demain sur l'ensemble du département
pour les écoles par exemple la mairie
des clayes-sous-bois informe sur les
réseaux sociaux que l'accueil dans les
écoles et pendant le temps périscolaire
sera encore fortement dégradée demain
attrape par exemple la restauration
scolaire est assuré mais il n'y aura pas
d'accueil périscolaire donc demain matin
et l'accueil de demain soir sera assuré
jusqu'à à 17 heures d'une manière
générale grégory sachez que les écoles
seront ouvertes demain dans toutes les
communes
mais elle accueille l'accueil se
rassurer mais il est fortement
recommandé de garder ou bien de faire
garder vos enfants
enfin pour les plus grands les étudiants
et réouvertures de l'ue vs qu demain
tous les sites sont concernés
petite précision pour les iut de vélizy
et de rambouillet les activités
reprendront à partir de 10h30 merci
oreiller pour ces précisions
la neige et le verglas ont aussi eu des
répercussions sur les entreprises de
saint quentin en yvelines des salariés
ne pouvant pas se rendre sur leur lieu
de travail certaines activités qui
tournent au ralenti
quelle était la situation aujourd'hui
nicolas landry quentin le frère ont fait
le point 7h30 ce jeudi matin sur le site
challenger bouygues construction de
guyancourt les premiers salariés
arrivent en voiture ils sont plus de
3000 à travailler ici
ils ont bravé la neige et le verglas
malgré les conseils donnés par la
préfecture de limiter les déplacements
en véhicule on a essayé de geler la
voiture et puis comme ça roulait à peu
près on a pris la voiture finalement
avait déjà hier je suis pas venu
travailler parce que les routes étaient
pas praticable ça c'est une chaussure et
ce matin les accès étaient bien dégagés
j'ai la chance d'habiter près d'aix
roulant ce qui fait que j'ai pas eu de
problème sur la route les nationales
sont très dégagé juste à bretelles en
arrivant sur le rond point là
leur emploi des sangliers sinon tout est
dégagé si le site de challenger semble
retrouver une activité normale cette
entreprise ini monteyne du bâtiment est
au ralenti impossible pour ce chef
d'entreprise d'utiliser ses véhicules
bloqués par la neige et le verglas
le gel a tout bloqué ils sont pas
conduisible pour lui la journée se
poursuit dans son bureau sur ses onze
salariés de ont pu venir travailler ce
matin des difficultés entraînant des
retards sur les chantiers et la perte
d'environ 15000 euros sur le chiffre
d'affaires j'ai un seul salarié sur un
seul chantier aujourd'hui qui
fait le travail qu'il devait faire c'est
à dire aujourd'hui appliqué des enduits
et penser moi j'habite dans le
centre-ville donc j'ai pris le cam ans
et puis j'ai roulé trop doucement
jusqu'au chantier quoi ce restaurant
anticiper les intempéries et
l'annulation des livraisons des produits
ont été stockés avant l'épisode neigeux
on a quand même réussi à ouvrir un on a
eu beaucoup moins de clients que
d'habitude à environ un tiers un tiers
voilà la préfecture d'île de france a
mis en place une cellule d'urgence pour
les entreprises impactées par les
intempéries
à l'heure actuelle aucune structure
yvelinoise n'a fait de déclaration pour
cet épisode neigeux impact sur
l'économie mais aussi à sur la politique
locale sachez que la séance du conseil
communautaire de saint quentin en
yvelines prévue ce soir est annulé allez
on referme cette page
intempéries dans le journal avec ce
sujet depuis deux jours vous avez pu
voir des images 2 ko vous n'êtes aussi a
sûrement pas passer à côté de scène plus
sympathique certains yvelinois se sont à
tout à fait à bien accommodé de la neige
une touche de sourire avec marylène yapi
chesneau doucement tout doucement
mieux vaut ne pas être pressé pour se
déplacer dans les yvelines depuis mardi
soir
[Musique]
même la déneigeuse de
voisins-le-bretonneux est prise au piège
enneigée à poissy les ennuis
s'accumulent là que laisse place à une
patinoire
la solution opter pour un mode de
transport plus adaptée mais pas moins
risqué de la neige sur la tour eiffel
sur l'arc de triomphe et même dans les
arènes de nîmes le parc france miniature
à immortaliser ce paysage peu habituelle
[Musique]
le château de versailles times nature a
lui aussi sorti son manteau de vison au
zoo de thoiry les animaux combien
participé aux batailles de boules de
neige
et à force d'amusement une nouvelle
population d'habitants s'est installé
dans tout le département
tous
[Musique]
et on enchaîne avec la suite de ce
journal la santé c'est une grande
préoccupation de nos sociétés nous
surveillons toujours les progrès de la
médecine qui contribuent à
l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie à
la santé à un sujet vaste donc que vous
avez traité christian portal dansoir
dont vous êtes l'auteur de ce livre
l'occident malade de sa médecine c'est
aux éditions libre et solidaire alors
c'est un livre critique sur le système
de santé aussi sur nos pratiques
médicamenteuse vous reconnaissez les
progrès médicaux vous mettez aussi en
avant l élite c'est proposer des
alternatives on va en parler dans un
instant déjà sur la démarche pourquoi un
livre sur la santé c'est une très longue
histoire s'est fait très longtemps que
je m'intéresse à cette question j'ai moi
même c'est toujours le même principe on
a eu des soucis de santé un moment donné
et puis on voit que ça s'est pas révélée
ou pas comme il faut donc on a trouvé
des alternatives et on s'aperçoit que ce
sont seuls ces alternatives qui ont
réussi à nous sortir des ennuis ensuite
je me suis intéressé à travers des
courants écologistes et serra et en fin
de compte
je me suis rendu compte que par exemple
à l'appel de paris de l'unesco du
professeur belpomme on parlait des pics
des pesticides des toxiques divers et
variés mais on ne parle jamais des
médicaments or pourtant les médicaments
c'est un point important puisque c'est
sur fabriqués par les mêmes entreprises
que celles qui fabriquent les pesticides
c'est les mêmes financements c'est les
mêmes et c'est surtout les mêmes
principes de penser de nombreux
scandales aussi on pense au médiator
relève au dialogue ce exact retour ces
médicaments exactement encore que le
levothyrox part exactement la même
nature ça fait partie des effets
secondaires liés à la gestion d'un
médicament compliqué à gérer
avec en plus un aspect qui est compliqué
qui est celui des génériques dans
lesquels on n'a pas la maîtrise sur tout
un ensemble d'éléments qui sont associés
à la molécule principale et c'est ce qui
fait d'ailleurs la différence d'usagé la
différence de des faits de nombreux
patients ne reconnaissent pas leurs
médicaments dans le médicament générique
ne reconnaissent pas les effets et donc
c'est effectivement un souci parce que
notre vision c'est la molécule fait le
travail
et puis le reste c'est l'accessoire 10
passe rien or il se passe beaucoup de
choses je prendre un exemple sur un
médicament par exemple paracétamol qui
est un médicament extrêmement banal que
tout le monde va prendre qui entre
parenthèses assad auld sa dose létale
est extrêmement proche de la dose
maximum c'est de l'ordre de 3 grammes or
en hôpital on donne facilement 4 g y
compris des gens ne sont pas en bon état
et le au contact du chlore ce
paracétamol se transforme en deux autres
molécules une génotoxique une
hépatotoxiques d'accord et le chlore
vous en avez dans l'eau de boisson
oui donc des tas de limites comme étant
en avant dans ce trip si on vient juste
sur votre parcours j'ai oublié le
précieux vous êtes yvelines l'origine au
delà de la vallée de chevreuse et la
santé c'est un sujet d'intérêt pour vous
vous êtes à l'origine notamment de la
création d'un collectif qui s'appelle à
ses commerces et agir pour une médecine
écologique qu'est ce que c'est la
médecine écologique pour notion ça
n'existe pas mais c'est en gros
l'équivalent pour la médecine de ce qu'a
été la démarche identique pour
l'agriculture c'est à dire qu' on essaie
de comprendre que les ravageurs les
éléments qui s'opposent quelque part à
la pousser des plantes sont des éléments
avec lesquels il faudra composer vouloir
éradiquer toute une série
d'inconvénients de ce type c'est
l'assurance des pires ennuis et des
impasses sur le problème de la
production et on se retrouve avec un
problème de biodiversité que l'on que
tout le monde condamne actuellement
parce que les pesticides les différents
produits toxiques ont attaqué
effectivement cette biodiversité
je considère qu effectivement au niveau
du corps humain niveau de décor vivant
il ya cette même biodiversité qu'il faut
respecter
et donc tout ce qui relève des idées des
vecteurs d'infection qu'il faudrait à
tout prix éradiquer ce par des vaccins
ou par des antibiotiques c'est une c'est
une erreur de paradigme tout simplement
alors dansez vous revenez bien sûr sur
les nombreux progrès médicaux du 20e
siècle
ça voulait les élus tepa mais en
revanche je vous dis tiens moi il ya
peut-être une fausse route qui a été
fait sur sur la santé notamment sur ce
paradis de l'infection c'est à dire que
nous avons vécu avec les microbes et
nous sommes ce que nous sommes aussi
grâce aux microbes
c'est à dire que on a fait cette
expérience de sup de de créer des souris
sans bactéries dans le tube digestif
elles ne vivent pas ne peuvent pas vivre
sur les solutions que vous avancez c'est
vrai que le temps avance vite les
solutions que vous avancez des
alternatives c'est quoi pour être c'est
très compliqué parce que c'est
alternative n'existe quasiment pas
pareil plusieurs raisons la première
c'est que le personnel médical capable
de faire ces alternatives est très peu
présent très peu efficace je tenais delà
d'un professeur de d'homéopathie relance
sananès disait sur 3000 homéopathie n'a
à peine 300 de convenable
donc on va tout de suite là il ya une
difficulté les produits homéopathiques
par exemple sont
deviennent de moins en moins efficace
parce qu'il ya des problèmes de
chauffage des souches il ya on supprime
un sérum de souche de de production n'a
pas donc tous les remèdes disponible
quand on les a c'est compliqué de les
obtenir parce qu'il ya toujours un délai
d'une journée de journée pour les avoir
donc comme par exemple mais elle pâtit
est une médecine d'urgence tunisienne
extrêmement efficace traitement rapide
mais c'est une médecine d'urgence il
faut deux jours pour obtenir un remède
le remède n'est plus bon cote la cote
c'est le moment de le prendre par
exemple
alors il nous reste 30 secondes
qu'espérez-vous avec cet ouvrage
finances a soit peut-être un manifeste
pour le futur essayé de réveiller les
consciences
s'il aurait bien eu conscience montrer
que finalement cette métiers qui se veut
performante qui se dit performantes ne
l'est pas tant que ça et qu'on aura
intérêt en tant que public à aller vers
d'autres choses et l'exigé merci à
christian portal d'avoir été avec nous
il y noie je le rappelle est auteur de
ce livre l'occident un malade de sa
médecine et je reprécise que ses taux
dès aux éditions libre et solidaire
métallique nous un mois d'éducation à
présent l'estac à l'école d'ingénieurs
et le lycée louis-blériot de trappes
travail en commun objectif concevoir un
aéroglisseur une occasion pour les
jeunes de découvrir les sciences et les
métiers de l'ingénierie
camille lambert quentin le frère et
nicolas landry ont assisté à un atelier
d engrenage des modèles de mécanique les
bases du projet les cordées de la
réussite
un programme national visant à favoriser
l'accès aux études supérieures
lycéens étudiants et professeurs oeuvre
dans un but commun créer un aéroglisseur
une expérience innovante apprécié par
les élèves du coup ben c'est intéressant
on fait des échanges avec les ingénieurs
de l'estaca
on apprend beaucoup moi je vais faire
dans les énergies renouvelables plus
tard
et quand je fais ça ici ses jupons de
donner un peu l'idée à ce que nos
charges et tarbes à travailler en équipe
développer ses connaissances ou tester
des prototypes
tous les moyens sont bons pour mettre
les élèves en confiance démission de
plusieurs heures organisée par les
professeurs toutes les deux semaines
à la base c'est fait en sorte que pour
les élèves des en des classes populaires
aient accès aux études supérieures et
surtout pour leur ouverture d'esprit il
se met en activité ils vont participer à
un projet de
d'écoles d'ingénieurs donc il y voyais
qu'ils peuvent et y arriver que
finalement c'est pas trop ça accessible
le projet est accessible à tous
contrairement aux idées reçues sur le
métier d'ingénieur pour les étudiants de
l'association pégase estaca c'est
l'occasion de partager une nouvelle
expérience pédagogique pour le plaisir
par passion pour donner l'envié de faire
ce que l'on fait pour que l'on fait
c'est vraiment un risque s'il s'agit en
fait de mixer le savoir intellectuel et
sa voix manuel la maquette du prototype
devrait voir le jour entre fin mai et
début juin à condition que tous
s'accordent sur le chemin de la réussite
la sport à présent avec eux du cyclisme
sur piste la sélection française pour
les mondiaux a été dévoilée ce mardi au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à des têtes
d'affiché retenue quentin lafargue
mathilde de gros ou encore ligne
montrent un françois pervis on retrouve
également un michael d'almeida le
plaisir ouaki fait à son retour depuis à
les jo-2016 mickaël millero un autre
michael elle a rencontré à mes côtés et
michael d'almeida la sélection française
pour les championnats du monde aux
pays-bas vient tout juste de tomber
michael d'almeida vous êtes dans
l'équipe vous réintégrer cette équipe
est ce que ça vous fait plaisir
première question plaisir oui bien
entendu c'est toujours une satisfaction
d'être sélectionné en équipe de france
donc
donc voila depuis depuis ma dernière
sélection entre guillemets aux jeux
olympiques qui s'est conclue par une
médaille de bronze tout de même
j'avais levé un peu le pied et puis
voilà me voilà de retour aux affaires
comme il faut c'était déjà dans les
cartons on peut le dire vous avez été
réintégré par l'équipe de france il ya
quelques semaines vous avez participé
des manches de coupe du monde également
est-ce que c'était prévisible cette
sélection elle était prévisible bien
entendu après moi ce n'était pas un
objectif que je m'étais fixé j'ai
derrière moi que quatre mois
d'entraînement le point d'interrogation
et sk en quatre mois
de quoi je serais capable en cap - oui
j'ai participé à une coupe du monde il
ya trois semaines
c'est encore une fois une sélection que
j'ai gagné c'était pas c'était pas un
acquis donc j'ai eu l'opportunité
d'aller m'exprime en coupe du monde et
lors de cette coupe du monde bat en en
réalisant les meilleurs temps personnels
à mon poste en vitesse par équipes
bon ben voila j'ai j'ai gagné ma
sélection maintenant pour pour les
championnats du monde qui seront à la
fin du mois la vitesse par équipes
ça sera votre épreuve phare du coût de
ces championnats du monde vous allez
partager cette vitesse par équipe avec
françois pervis également sébastien
vigier un cycliste on peut le dire
expérimenté un autre un peu moins
expérimenté qui a qu'à 20 ans est ce que
c'est le bon compromis finalement le bon
compromis
c'est d'avoir des athlètes qui vont vite
voilà pour moi pour moi l'expérience
l'expérience c'est quelque chose qui
s'obtient avec avec les années avec la
pratique
sébastien vigier a quand même pratique
et beaucoup de vitesse par équipes
d'ailleurs de très belle manière très
honorable donc voilà pour moi c'est pour
moi c'est quelqu'un qui a déjà de
l'expérience qui va en avoir encore j'en
aurai moi aussi encore lors de lors de
ces championnats et puis on peut prendre
le contre exemple de françois qui est
plus vieux que moi et qui pourtant n'a
pas fait beaucoup de championnats du
monde en vitesse par équipes a aussi
paradoxalement que ça puisse paraître
donc voilà l'expérience l'expérience et
c'est pas une question d'âge c'est une
question pratique et on en acquiert tout
au long de sa carrière justement
avec des expériences comme çà de là vous
pensez que vous serez et favori de ces
championnats du monde
je l'espère j'en sais trop rien pour
l'instant c'est difficile pour moi pour
moi de me prononcer je suis quelqu'un
d'assez pragmatique et ambitieux donc
voila moi mon ambition bien entendu
c'est qu'on soit les meilleurs
maintenant voilà est-ce qu'on est les
favoris je sais pas ce n'est pas à moi
de le dire par contre je pense que on en
fait partie
faut pas se le cacher l'équipe de france
ne doit pas viser autre chose qu'une
médaille
maintenant voilà la couleur de la
médaille on verra contre qui on luttera
justement je pense que dès les
qualifications on verra ça me permettra
un mois de jauger voilà le niveau global
de notre équipe de d'avoir un état aussi
de des autres équipes et puis voilà à
partir de là part à partir des
qualifications je pense qu'on pourra
établir directement est-ce qu'on joue le
titre ou ou pas les entraînements déjà
commencé avec vous trois à avec nos
trois oui oui bien entendu les
entraînements ont déjà commencé après
ben y'a pas y'a pas non plus en pratique
et plus qu'il n'en faut on se connaît on
fait du vélo ensemble tous les jours
voilà ce qui ce qui compte c'est juste
prendre quelques petits repères mais
encore une fois les repères c'est comme
l'expérience s'acquiert lors des
compétitions
donc voilà on fait ce qu'on sait faire
on se parle entre nous on s'explique un
peu comment chacun on voit les choses et
puis voilà après on fera parler la
poudre sur la piste et ce qui compte
après c'est s'exprimer et sa voix voilà
montrer ce qu'on a dans les jambes et
sortir un chrono puis le reste le reste
a su de votre côté ce qu'il ya de
l'appréhension
non non non il n'y a pas d'appréhension
du tout il ya au contraire de
l'excitation
l'appréhension elle était plutôt il ya
quelques semaines en arrière que j'ai
quand j'étais sélectionnée pour la
manche de coupe du monde à minsk voilà
là j'avais un petit peu d'appréhension
de de savoir où j'en étais moins à titre
personnel avec seulement quatre mois
d'entraînement dans les jambes et bomba
j'ai pu me rassurer aussi entre
guillemets en voyant que je faisais
toujours partie des meilleurs mondiaux
et que j'avais même battu mon record
personnel donc non il a strictement
aucune appréhension contraire moi les
championnats du monde et jeux olympiques
cdc des compétitions qui galvanise donc
donc non je suis je suis prêt et excité
dernière question vous aviez remporté
une médaille d'or aux championnats du
monde ici à saint quentin en yvelines
sur cette piste qui est juste derrière
nous est-ce que vous allez remporter une
quelques semaines bien sûr je vais pour
ça et puis bah pour l'anecdote apeldoorn
c'est là où j'ai obtenu mon premier
titre de champion du monde aussi en 2011
donc voilà c'est pas ce n'est pas une
piste on va pas dans l'inconnu
j'ai été champion du monde là bas aussi
j'étais champion du monde ici à saint
quentin alors maintenant à chaque fois
que je saute je sors de toute façon
c'est pour donner le meilleur de moi
même et si le meilleur de moi-même c'est
d'être champion du monde voilà je ne
m'en prive pas je prends donc donc voilà
maintenant
maintenant il faut se concentrer encore
sur l'entraînement qui reste à accomplir
d'aujourd'hui à aux championnats du
monde et puis et puis voilà dès le 28
je ferai parler la poudre merci michael
d'almeida les championnats du monde aux
pays-bas c'est du 28 février au 4 mars
avant de se quitter petit rappel sur la
météo dans les yvelines la neige est
attendu de nouveau dans le dès le petit
matin département le département qui
reste d'ailleurs ce soir en vigilance
orange
et ce jusqu'à samedi 7h au moins deux
nouveaux ça a été confirmé cet
après-midi les transports scolaires ne
seront pas assurés à demain dans les
yvelines des perturbations également à
prévoir sur les routes et dans les
transports en commun une situation qui
va évoluer continuellement et pour
rester informé je vous invite à
consulter régulièrement les sites qui
sont affichés ceux de la préfecture des
yvelines de météo france et du
transilien et ce soir en continue
d'ailleurs de parler à des intempéries
dans les yvelines dans le 7-8 débat
amanda bherer et rivera posera cette
question à nos invités le chaos
était-il évitable dans le département
c'est la fin de ce journal reportages et
replay a consultés sur notre site
internet et sur notre application mobile
tv 78 très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]